round seven of the US and US Women's  Chess Championships here in st. Louis it  was the day after the rest day when the  best players in the country came back  recharged refreshed and ready for battle  viata Soria continued to play giant  killer by taking down the Cara Nakamura  while World Championship challenger  Fabiano Khurana smashed through bar  copious defenses to vault into a tie for  first but the story of the event remains  fifteen-year-old anyway whose  determination in defense rewarded her  with a win against an acerbic leaving  the teenage sensation a shocking full  point ahead of the rest of the field  it's do or die time in a rush for Glory  round eight action coming up next